cette vidéo est faite en partenariat
avec des slides vous en reparle en fin
de vidéo
je trouve qu'ils veulent mais ce qu est
incroyable je sais je sais y en a parmi
vous qui grincent des dents sévère mais
je m'expliquais ça fait des années que
je suis ce qu'il fait d'être une petite
quinzaine d'années entre comme ça et je
vais vous raconter comment il a fait
fortune avec son frère il fonde un truc
qui s'appelle type 2 qui est un éditeur
de logiciels de publication en ligne et
ziv 2 se fait ensuite racheté pour 341
millions de dollars
lui il se fait environ 22 millions de
dollars à 27 ans il investit tout ça
dans une nouvelle entreprise qu'il crée
une banque en ligne qui s'appelle x.com
et qui devient essentiellement et y
parle il revend paypal il se fait 180
millions de dollars et réinvestir cet
argent dans l'essentiel mans trois
boîtes dont une dont il est le fondateur
space x
les deux autres boîtes c'était cela qui
fait des voitures électriques et solar
cities qui fait des panneaux solaires
c'est hyper résumé un mais en gros c'est
l'idée après il fonde aussi hyper loupé
le but i qu'on se déplace hyper vite
dans des capsules
il a fait aussi la bourrine compagnie
rires des tunnels sous la ville pour
qu'on se déplace plus vite et ne ralink
qui fait des implants cérébraux et le
but voilà ces deux c'est de créer des
synergies entre l'homme et
l'intelligence artificielle voilà le mec
fait mille trucs à la fois et tous ces
trucs
son style est alors évidemment c'est un
personnage extrêmement controversée par
par rapport à ses déclarations par
rapport à son attitude arrondissement au
début de la crise de qourna virus voilà
il disait à ses employés de ne pas hâter
les travailler et d'aller sur le site
etc
voilà c'est un exemple il y en a plein
de trucs comme ça évidemment je ne suis
pas d'accord avec tout ce qu'il dit tout
ce qu'il prône tout ce qu'il dégage
évidemment mais ça n'empêche que j'ai de
l'admiration pour lui complexité humaine
tout ça voilà les gens ne sont pas tout
blanc ou tout noir
et j'imagine qu'on en reparlera dans une
vidéo parce que je trouve que ça manque
un petit peu aujourd'hui
généralement on juge les gens dans leur
entièreté il suffit d'un truc qu'on
n'aime pas pour jeter la personne en
entier quoi je trouve ça nul
j'ai pas envie de faire ça et quoi qu'on
en dise le mec est un génie et
l'influencé qu'il a sur notre monde
moderne est indécente
d'autant plus que j'ai l'impression que
il se fait plus embêté quand il réussit
parce qu'il ya dix ans quand c'était le
seul qui croyaient en tesla ou en space
x là bizarrement il y avait assez peu de
monde qui l'embêtait quoi mais c'est pas
le but de cette vidéo
le but de cette vidéo c'est comprendre
comment il fait quoi comment il faisait
lui aussi là que 24 heures sa journée
comment il fait pour faire cette vidéo
je me suis essentiellement basé sur un
poste de d'anne sylvestre qui parle de
sa lecture de lots de masques
tesla space x and the quest for
fantastic fincher après ferrari que le
poste lui-même s'appuie sur une vision
thomass franck donc bref on est à partir
de cette lecture on va dégager 7 types
ce qu'ils vont pas nous permettre d'être
aussi balèze colonnes masque mais qui
vont nous permettre de booster notre
productivité
parce que si vous avez du talent et vous
avez de belles choses à apporter à ce
monde
ce serait dommage de pas le faire pour
des questions de productivité commencé
avec le plus important il se lève
globalement à 7 heures et pendant une
demi heure etc travaillent sur ces
emails et répondent aux plus importants
notamment ceux qui bloquent le travail
des autres c'est ce qu'il explique dans
ce speech où il parle de focus hand
signals donc l'idée c'est identifier
votre tâche la plus importante de la
journée
votre vraie priorité est de commencer
par ça gérer les contacts à votre
vitesse la suite logique de ce premier
conseil c'est que bah si vous commencez
votre journée par le plus important vous
n'êtes pas forcément disponibles pour
communiquer avec les autres c'est pour
ça que musk privilégie au maximum les
moyens de communication qui lui
permettent de communiquer quand il le
veut comme par exemple les emails ou
même les messages en général c'est même
quelque chose qu'il dit lui même
j'aime les emails tant que possible
j'essaie de communiquer de manière
asynchrone
je suis très bon en email on va pas se
mentir en 2021 c'est une compétence non
négligeable alors nous ce qu'on peut
faire un autre gel pour appliquer ce
conseil c'est quoi c'est d'abord couper
ces notifications
n'acceptez pas tous les meetings moi y'a
plein de meetings que je refuse parce
qu'on voit là je dis j'ai pas le temps
pour ça ou est-ce qu'on peut pas parler
dans un premier temps par e-mail est ce
qu'on peut pas régler d'abord ses
questions là par e-mail et souvent savez
mon agente qui me protège parce que elle
me dit ok ils veulent que tu sois là sur
cette réunion mais y'a pas besoin que tu
sois là à ce stade donc pour l'instant
concentre toi sur tes vidéos et moi je
gère le meeting et c est moi au lieu de
fermer vidéo je fais une story d'une
heure sur des grillons voilà je suis
vraiment dans cette logique de limiter
au maximum les meetings et travailler de
chez soi
moi en ce moment c'est facile même trop
en fait on traîne trop de chez soi mais
l'idée c'est que cette vidéo soit aussi
intemporel soit des conseils qui servent
tout le temps et honnêtement qu'on
travaille de chez soi on est beaucoup
moins sollicité et donc du coup beaucoup
moins d'interruptions etc
là et je sais comme ça nous manque en ce
moment tout ça ça permet de prendre du
contrôle sur sa manière de communiquer
avec les autres et donc ça permet
d'avoir de longs moments de longues
tranches horaires
on peut travailler sans interruption et
ça c'est hyper important notamment si
vous avez un job créatif je sais que moi
par exemple le montage ou l'écriture
d'une vidéo c'est hyper important
d'avoir un gros bloc sans interruption
le multi tasking c'est très difficile
d'avoir le job d'elon musk d'être dans
toutes ses boîtes sans avoir recours au
multi tasking alors concrètement c'est
quoi il va regrouper des tâches de même
nature c'est aussi un procédé qu'on
appelle le bashing
ça vient de batch qui en anglais veut
dire l'eau et c'est pas qu'une question
de tâches similaires c'est aussi une
question de moment par exemple voilà on
peut réunir le fait d'avoir un meeting
une réunion est le fait des jeunes et
hop on les met ensemble et lui il pousse
le truc assez loin quand même parce
qu'il a cette phrase j'ai réalisé que je
pouvais être avec mes enfants et être
quand même sur mes emails
je peux être avec eux et quand même
travailler en même temps si je n'avais
pas cette capacité
je ne pourrais pas faire ce que j'ai à
faire ont personnellement c'est un
concert que je trouve hyper compliquée à
mettre en oeuvre
ça dépend aussi de ou est-ce que vous en
êtes dans votre vie c'est quoi vos
objectifs comment vous voulez passer du
temps avec les êtres qui vous entoure et
ces voix là ça dépend de plein de choses
en revanche un truc est applicable quoi
qu'il arrive c'est de batx et des tâches
qui demandent le même état d'esprit des
tâches similaires
par exemple pour moi écrire une vidéo
youtube voilà si je peux en écrire 2 2 à
la suite pourquoi pas ou écrire des
newsletters
ce que je fais clairement pas assez ou
gérer mes emails ou faire ma compta est
donc dédié vraiment toute ma compta le
mettre au même moment ce genre de trucs
en fait je serais beaucoup plus efficace
à faire trois heures d'écriture ou trois
heures d'administratifs de suite qu'une
heure par ci une heure par là etc
mais pour ça faut avoir une bonne image
de ce qui nous attend au terme de taf et
ça ça tombe bien c'est le conseil sur
prioriser la jambe
la plupart des gens partent de leur to
do list et commence la journée comme ça
là l'idée c'est pas de fonctionner avec
sa to do list mais de fonctionner avec
son agenda
alors juste me permets un petit truc
parce que sur la vidéo avec marc aurel
etc
j'ai pas mal parlé de tout doux et il ya
des gens qui n'ont pas forcément compris
dans les commentaires ce que c'était
j'en suis désolé je m'explique très
rapidement tous d'où ça vient l'anglais
est donc en anglais ça veut dire affaire
est donc une to do list
c'est une liste de choses à faire voilà
tout simplement une liste des tâches est
en fait cette fois où le prendre votre
liste de tâches et de les faire au fur
et à mesure vous prenez votre agenda et
vous mettez ces tâches dans votre agenda
en fonction du temps qu'elles prennent
par exemple dans ma tout doux
aujourd'hui j'ai abaissé à c'est
vraiment ma tâche la plus importante
donc souvenez-vous bah je vais commencer
par ça b je peux le faire vite fait
pendant le des jets cetera parce que
c'est un truc qui me demandent à cette
passivité
c'est de regarder une vidéo par exemple
pour faire un retour sur je sais pas
quoi donc je le fais à ce moment là et
c'est je prends deux heures dans l'après
midi pour le faire et en fait le gros
avantage de travailler directement dans
son agenda c'est que ça permet de
beaucoup mieux se projeter dans le temps
alors elle admet ce qu'apparemment il
fonctionne par des tranches de 5 minutes
donc des blocs de cinq minutes
donc voilà c'est très très court moi
personnellement j'utilise cette
technique depuis pas mal de temps déjà
c'est venu un peu instinctivement à
force d'avoir une to do list très vite
j'ai commencé à remplir l'agenda et je
trouve ça beaucoup plus clair pour moi
c'était mieux pour mon organisation et
je sais que personnellement j'utilise
des blocs d'une demi-heure et j'ai vu
que c'était apparemment assez commun
voilà donc celle que j'ai pas un blog
qui fait moins d'une demi heure dans
l'agenda
évidemment l'idée c'est de tout mettre
sert le moindre appel téléphonique la
moindre promenade le moindre rendez vous
bref faut que tout soit dans l'agenda et
même des petits trucs perso j'en par
exemple épilation du sillon intéressiez
ce genre de truc développer son savoir
kim balle le frère d'ellen petite
parenthèse d'ailleurs leurs prénoms sont
trop stylé stroking balle le frère
d'ellen disait que dans leur jeunesse
elon lisez jusque 2 livres par jour tous
les jours voilà ça me semble beaucoup il
devait lire très vite ou peut-être
qu'ils les aient pas tout en entier
enfin voila c'était souvent des livres
non fictionnelle donc voilà ça se
limitait pas pareil quand bref en tout
cas entre le mythe et la réalité peu
importe
jusque ce qui compte et l'idée qu'il
faut retenir c'est que ils s'instruisent
est beaucoup et dans le livre d'ailleurs
il ya manqué marquant où il ya un
employé qui raconte que musk arrive pour
lui poser des questions et dit la chose
suivante
au début je pensais qu'il essayait de
voir si je savais de quoi je parlais
puis ensuite j'ai réalisé qu'il essayé
d'apprendre il peut vous poser des
questions jusqu'à ce qu'il apprenne 90%
des choses que vous savez et ça ça a
permis à masquer de développer des
compétences en forme de t thi shaked ce
qui est alors c'est une terminologie qui
est assez intéressante qui a déjà
quelques années et qu'on retrouve par
exemple dans les manuels des nouveaux
employés de chez valve valve c'est le
studio derrière steam half life counter
strike portal voilà c'est une entreprise
qui est assez fascinante et en fait elle
a une organisation structurelle
horizontale c'est un endroit ya pas de
bosses les bureaux ils ont des roulettes
pour vous puissiez les déplacés où vous
voulez et travailler avec qui vous
voulez c'est ouf
et donc dans leurs manuels il explique
ce que c'est le tiche ait skis haut
c'est les gens qui sont à la fois
généraliste donc très compétent sur une
multitude de choses importantes
la barre du thé l'oci experts parmi les
meilleurs d'une discipline précise c'est
la verticale du thé et ben ça c'est
quelque chose qui a permis à musk
d'innover de collaborer avec des gens
dans d'autres disciplines et d'être
hyper créatif et c'est quelque chose que
vous pouvez faire vous aussi en
formalisant votre thé en le mettant avec
de l'eau chaude et en laissant à fuser
je sais pas cinq minutes suivant la
nature du thé
voilà je déconseille le sucre évidemment
le matin c'est très bien et elle vous
l'avez pas vu venir celle là en fait
juste voilà on formalise son thé et on
regarde comment veulent agrandir que ce
soit horizontalement ou verticalement
voilà il fallait un stylo on se dit
voilà mes compétences et ça ça ça
m'intéresse je peux partir dans cette
direction là et ça je le développe et se
remettre constamment en question
dans une interview mais ce qui nous dit
la chose suivante je pense que c'est
très important d'avoir une boucle de
feedback où vous penser constamment à ce
que vous avez fait et comment vous
pouvez l'améliorer je pense que si
j'avais un seul conseil à donner ce
serait celui-là penser constamment à
comment vous pourriez faire les choses
d'une meilleure façon et remettez vous
en question
c'est un conseil assez fort de l'admdq
et qui est assez logique finalement
puisque si vous vous améliorez chaque
jour et chaque semaine
inexorablement vous rapprocher de vos
objectifs à titre perso c'est pour ça
que à chaque nouvel an je vous parle de
nouvelle résolution
et que chaque année voilà je me force à
avoir des résolutions des objectifs et
que j'essaie de les respecter et rien
que le fait de se donner des objectifs
ça nous force à nous demander et faire
une introspection sur voilà qu'est ce
qu'on a envie d'améliorer qu'est-ce qui
va pas et c est donc une remise en
question
je trouve qu'une note bonne manière de
faire ça c'est c'est une manière que
certains potes qui me trouvais un peu
zinzin de faire ça mais moi j'aimais
bien j'avoue c'était de noter sa journée
voilà je notais ma journée
chaque fin de journée jeannot t'es quoi
il est à noter en termes de est-ce que
je suis content de ce que j'ai accompli
aujourd'hui quoi en eau et donc du coup
quand il y avait une mauvaise note ça
permet de voir ce qu'il va pas quoi
alors parfois c'était accidentel
sa queue il ya un truc qui fait que dans
la journée voilà j'ai une voix là je me
suis donné mauvaise note parce que
j'étais pas content d'un truc et c'est
pas grave ce qui est grave c'est quand
ça commence à arriver souvent et très
souvent et donc ce n'est pas accidentel
c'est structurel quoi c'est à dire qu'il
ya un truc que je fais qui me va pas il
y avait quelque chose ou quelqu'un dans
cet environnement qui baissaient cette
note est donc je voulais l'identifier
mais si je me mettais pas tous les jours
je pense que j'aurais mis beaucoup plus
de temps à réaliser ce qui n'allait pas
et donc régler le problème
après j'ai pas du tout en train de vous
dire noté votre journée mais par contre
effectivement ce conseil de masques sur
se créer une boucle de feedback et se
remettre en question je trouve hyper
important prendre sa douche
alors ça c'est plus un conseil un petit
peu rigolo ça fait référence à une faq
que elon musk a fait sur reddit et à une
des questions c'était quel est votre
habitude quotidienne qui à l'impact
positif le plus gros sur votre vie et la
mort ce qu'a répondu prendre la douche
alors ça ressemble à une vanne mais
prend une autre interview il parle du
rapport positif que lui offre la douche
notamment par rapport à la créativité
c'est hier le fait que souvent la douche
donne des idées ou permet de résoudre
des problèmes je trouve en tout cas moi
ça m'arrive
personnellement et je suis sûr que
nombre d'entre vous aussi d'ailleurs il
ya même des groupes facebook genre
pensée sous la douche et c'est une chose
saute cesser les concepts assez connu de
de pensée sous la douche qui sont un peu
marre entre donc peut-être que vous
pourrez implémenter certains de ses
conseils dans votre routine ou que vous
les implémenter déjà et dans ce cas là
je suis assez curieux de savoir votre
ressenti et comment vous vous le faites
et c'est toujours hyper intéressant de
voir comment les gens font chacun de
leur côté et tout parce que je pense
qu'on a pas mal à s'échanger sur ce
genre de truc en tout cas moi c'est des
sujets qui me passionnent
après un autre élément qui peut être
aussi de votre productivité s'est évité
les mini problème qui prennent la tête
et qui prennent de l'énergie de cerveau
pour rien quoi comme par exemple
toujours oublié son mot de passe
edit donc ce serait pas l'heure du
sponsor de cette vidéo
heureusement les amis il existe des
gestionnaire de mots de passe et
personnellement ça fait un an et demi à
peu près que j'utilise d'acheter
j'utilise pour gérer tous mes mots de
passe en rouge me connecte à un site
d'ashley memories le mot de passe
il me le propose quand je me reconnecte
à nouveau sur ce site
et quand je crée un compte ce que j'aime
bien c'est que il me propose de me créer
un mot de passe et de générer un mot de
passe sur hyper complexe qu'ils
sauvegardent directement parce qu'il
faisait flipper et ce qui fait que tu as
mis du temps à voir un gestionnaire de
mots de passe c'est que j'avais peur que
mon ac bon gestionnaire de mots de passe
mais c'est en fait c'est pas possible
parce que dash lane ne stocke aucun mot
de passe sur son serveur en fait toutes
les chiffrer et la clé de chiffrement
c'est votre mot de passe
m c'est à dire le mot de passe que vous
utilisez pour vous connecter à daschle
et qui n'est pas stocké non plus donc
perso mon mot de passe c'est carrément
une phrase qui est tellement galère que
là
part du temps je me courent en rentrant
dans mon espace d'acheter et une fois
que je rentre j'ai accès à tous mes mots
de passe autre intérêt vous pouvez
rentrer directement vos corps des cartes
bancaires comme ça se remplit quand il
ya besoin est pareil même sécurité que
sur les mots de passe et l'autre cool
c'est qu'un vpn a intégré ce qui va vous
n'êtes pas obligé d'avoir mis les outils
pour gérer votre sécurité sur internet
si tout cela vous intéresse vous pouvez
l'essayer gratuitement ouais ouais ouais
gratuitement sur d'acheter inc.com slash
cyrus vance et si vous voulez la version
premium vous pouvez avoir moins 50 % -
50 avec le code cyrus tance examen
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
et qu'elle vous aura inspiré qu'elle
vous aura donné envie d'être encore plus
productif ou au jus de l'être parce que
j'ai encore plus mais ce qu'on voulait
pas du tout donc voilà elle chante
souvent la productivité ça colle aussi
avec le fait d'avoir un projet qui vous
anime un taf qui vous botte et c'est sûr
que c'est un bon révélateur aussi se
dire que quand il en a envie d'être
productif et on se rend compte que la
bataille a un souci avec ce qu'on fait
dans nos taf et donc du coup plus fait
de vouloir est positif entraîne des
ajustements dans notre taf est en fait
les deux n'apporte que du positif l'un
envers l'autre
je trouve encore merci à d'acheter in
avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo est à vous
de l'avoir regardé
suivez moi sur instagram et d'ailleurs
j'ai commencé à recevoir plein de photos
de vous avec les tee-shirts les pulls
etc
voilà ça me ça me touche énormément ça
me fait énormément plaisir je suis trop
content love peace ciao